hey everybody and welcome to live coding
with Jesse still trying to get
everything set up just give me a second
the stream quality wasn't great so I've
been trying to close out everything I
can okay
think we have it now all right so
welcome everyone I imagine we probably
will have some newer some new viewers on
the stream because this is very beginner
friendly it's gonna be pretty much basic
HTML so if you're new this is how things
go on the stream we break up the stream
into periods where we code and then
periods where we where I answer
questions in the live chat so after I
explain what we're gonna do I'll start
my first coding session and that'll be a
25-minute
Pomodoro session what I'm gonna do today
is pretty basic so it may only take one
Pomodoro session but if we don't get it
done in the first session we'll do a
second one after a five-minute break to
go through the live chat if you have any
questions at any point please put it in
the live chat I may not see it at first
but I'll definitely get to it before I
end the stream the streams usually last
about an hour hour-and-a-half
occasionally we've gone longer than that
but I think today it should be an hour
or less so I apologize for those of you
that get motion sick easily I'm on a
laptop right now let's sitting in my lap
and I'm using the the webcam from there
so the image of my face may be a bit
shaky I'm gonna keep that small the
whole time I'm not gonna make it
fullscreen because I know I
get motion sick easily I don't want to
do that to you all I have a legit webcam
that is that I ordered and it should be
in tomorrow so hopefully for Friday
stream when I stream from home
I'll have that webcam and I also have a
tripod for it so it should be better
picture quality and nice and steady so I
see a lot of you saying hi and so hey
everyone I'm gonna go ahead and start
the the stream it looks like we have a
bunch of people in here and the stream
quality is good so I'm gonna start this
Promotora session and we're gonna get
right into coding I put a link to this
repository in the description to the
video so if you go to that link this is
where it'll take you this is a static
HTML site for the clinical mental health
counseling program the university that I
worked for work for offers a program for
counseling and so we gave them a
separate site as part of a marketing
campaign we're going to run another
marketing campaign for them so I
received some edits and I actually have
the edits on a sheet of paper with
post-it notes because my coworker asked
me a while back on slack how do you want
me to send the changes and I being a
smart I like said on on paper with a
number-two pencil please of course I was
joking but she when I came into my
office the next time this had been slid
under my door which has a note on it
that says be careful what you ask for so
I'm gonna be explaining what's on this
piece of paper to you all as we go
through so let's check out let's check
out the site so I can explain what we're
gonna change since whoops all right I
didn't really want it to go in a
separate window but that'll work since
you all probably have never
seen the site before I want you to be
familiar with it
so basically some of these design
elements should be familiar to you but
this is kind of the first site where we
went with this this header style of
being kind of the light header so it has
some of the new design elements and some
elements that we don't really use
anymore
but the first thing that definitely
needs to change is we need to use our
newer logo and if you've seen past
streams you've seen the newer logo so
we're gonna be changing out a logo and
we may have to adjust the CSS there so
there'll be some basic CSS we also are
going to need to change this text and we
are going to need to change we're gonna
need to remove some elements so we have
some elements here and it also switches
and there are certain things on the page
that are only visible either on mobile
or on desktop so we'll have to make the
changes in both versions so we'll get to
see you know how and I think all the
changes so you see there's not really a
lot than these change but like I said
this will be a good stream for beginners
I am gonna explain you know the
structure of what I'm doing and why
we're doing things as I go on and
there'll be a lot of times time for
questions okay and if you want I'm gonna
copy and paste the the link to this site
so you all can check it out on your own
computers and then like I said the link
I'm gonna link this github repo in the
live chat if you're watching this and
somehow don't have access to the live
chat the links also in the description
to this video so I don't even have this
installed on my laptop yet laptop yet so
I'm gonna be super basic and first thing
we're gonna do is clone this repository
so you may or may not be familiar with
github so I've gone to this repository I
clicked this Green clone or download
button don't worry about the dark
background on this I have some custom
themes going on github so this is the
regular version of github that
you all can see as well so I've copied
this and now we're gonna go to my
terminal and let me make it a bit bigger
for you all make sure you can see it so
I'm gonna explain what I'm doing in the
terminal just in case there's some of
you out there that aren't really
familiar with with the terminal I am on
a Mac so these are going to be Mac
commands they'll also work on Linux the
commands may be a bit different on on a
PC or on a windows-based machine so the
first thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
change directory with CD and I'm gonna
go into my projects folder and in my
projects folder here's here all my
projects that I've been working on I
like to keep them all in one folder like
this and now I need to do a git clone
and I'm gonna paste in that link that I
just copied from github and when I do
this it's going to make a new folder
right that's called CMHC site this
clinical mental health counseling site
right so it just makes a folder that has
the same name as your get repo so now
what that folder is made let's go into
that folder now we're in there and let's
just check out the files we'll do an LS
to check out all the files we can see we
have some basic files and what we need
to do so we have this package JSON file
we can see we have a yarn lock file so
this project was made with yarn instead
of regular NPM so let's go ahead and do
a yarn we're just gonna type in the
command yarn that's going to install all
the packages for this package JSON file
okay so we're not gonna go into that now
cuz I want to stick to basic HTML so if
you if you want to know more about your
package JSON file what's going on here
just put a question into the chat or in
the comments and then I can answer that
in more depth later on in the stream so
let's see while this is running let's
get this open so I'm going to duplicate
the tab and I'm gonna open this up in
Visual Studio code
so I'm just going to type in code and
then a period and that should open
everything up in Visual Studio code for
us which it may take a while this this
particular laptop is a bit slow there we
are
another instance of code is running but
not responding okay I guess we'll close
this
let's check this out all right this is
my other instance of code that's running
I'd rather not shut this down because
I'm working on that let's see okay it
looks like it's working it's just taking
a while apologies for the slowness of
the machine when I'm trying to run my
streaming software and do this at the
same time it does slow down the Machine
a bit when I stream at my office of a
more powerful machine and it doesn't
slow it we're not gonna upgrade right
now we're gonna do that later and let's
see what is going on here nope that is
not the project that I wanted did i
duplicate the wrong tab looks like
accidentally duplicated the wrong tab so
I guess let's just check out let's
duplicate the right tab now close that
there we are
and we'll just do the same command which
we need to wait a minute anyway because
while our packages are installing so I
wanted to do this on the stream with
everybody watching so you like you get
an idea of how this works so I didn't
anticipate it taking quite so long but
it does give us it gives me time to
check out some of the questions in the
live stream while we're waiting so I'm
gonna go in the stream and just kind of
check out what's going on I'm gonna
start at the top here and I'm gonna keep
an eye on this this other monitor here
so that when it's ready we can get right
into it
hey harsh it's in here he's it's perfect
time so hard [ __ ] the times when there
are certain is a little bit difficult to
catch a stream in so
I'm really glad that you could watch
today harsh it does shut up Prasad so I
don't know how to pronounce your entire
name but hopefully that's let me know if
I pronounce that part right says hi it's
my first time with Jesse hey welcome
thanks for watching hopefully this
stream has some good stuff for you today
himemiya so solo wow there's a lot of
look I'm not gonna read through
everybody's name to settle oh I'm just a
lot of hellos thank you all so much okay
so now we have some code up here that we
can check out so we're gonna go into
where's our index page this is a
one-page HTML site so we're gonna go
into our index page and I'm gonna make
the code as big as I can so that you all
can see and I'm gonna scroll down a bit
let's let's move this over here so we
give us some more space I'm gonna scroll
to if you as I scroll I'm not gonna go
through everything on the site but I'm
just gonna explain a little bit so you
can see this looks like a regular HTML
page right we have our HTML tag or head
tag right we're importing some things up
here importing a JavaScript and CSS
library called materialized to help us
this is an older version of materialized
so if some of the things in here look
different to you because you're used to
a newer version definitely go with
whatever the newer stuff is don't take
this as you know the way to do things
because I'm sure some of the some of the
ways that we're doing things may not
even be supported in the newer versions
this site was developed over a year ago
let's see so we have our navigation and
let's see where logo is here we go so
the first thing that we're gonna edit is
our logo and let's check on this still
going
all right so let me bring over our logo
we can at least put our logo in there
and the easiest thing I think would be
to name our logos the same name logos
okay so let me grab my logo so I'm gonna
open up a Finder window just on my other
screen because I have some Finder
windows open already so let's see I
think I downloaded a logo this logo that
I need to use not too long ago and I
think I have an SVG version of it which
I'm hoping it's an SVG version I prefer
those and it would be cool to just show
you all how we use SVG's in case you you
haven't seen that before
um I have a bunch of SVG's just name
logo so I'm looking through the previews
just to make sure that I have the right
SVG
okay here we are I found it so let's
copy that and let's see if I can paste
it directly in the ear into the images
folder it's not gonna let me do that
let's see if I can
hmmm alright doesn't let me copy in the
pace so I guess I'm gonna need to drag
and drop this within finder
so I'm doing this on my other screen
because this is just basic like I
searched her file and now I'm gonna drag
and drop it somewhere okay so now we
have our logo here and what we can do is
just delete this logo I know you know
what they have different file the
endings anyway so can't do it like that
let's just change every instance here of
this side logo so what we'll do is do a
ctrl F right to find it and then we will
let's see how we open this up there we
are and then we're going to replace it
with this FUS logo SVG and you see we
have replaced or replace all we're gonna
do replace all alright and now we need
to see what this looks like so hopefully
oh goodness
it's still going
building fresh matters all right we'll
go we'll go ahead and replace some more
stuff where's this refer to cool logo
I'm not sure where we're using this
let's check it out I guess in the footer
maybe oh here we are
okay we are using that in the footer I
think we can keep this I don't I'm like
I don't think that's an issue it wasn't
something that was marked to be changed
so we're gonna keep that in the footer
but just notice how crisp this is
because it's an SVG
zoomed in there's you know it looks fine
it doesn't look pixelated at all
let's compare that to to this up here if
we zoom in it's actually not too bad it
must be a decent sized image but I don't
know if you could see it on your screen
but I noticed some fuzziness around the
edges here so that's why I really like
SVG's is that no matter how much you
blow them up or zoom in there they work
they still look fine okay looks like
there's a lot going on in the live chat
here I will get to that soon let me
check my timer alright about 10 minutes
so it looks like this logo is the only
logo that we had that we need to deal
with I know I named it side nav logo but
really you know I don't have another
logo in here so this is what we were
working with and I'm gonna delete this
since we don't need it anymore all right
so that should be OK for beginning the
logo in as soon as my yarn command gets
through everything that it needs to we
can run this locally and see the changes
if for some reason it doesn't work I can
just open this in Chrome without having
like the auto refresh and stuff
happening so that that should work the
thing the one thing that we're gonna
have to make sure that may not work is
the the style so you know the image we
had in there before was a certain size
this is an SVG you know the the size
could throw things off but hopefully it
won't
now we need to find michael says there's
hardly anything in your package file not
sure what's taking so long we building
first bike engines I guess we could I
mean it could just be that I'm trying to
run OBS at the same time let's you know
what I'm just gonna stop this process
and let's try it again just you know
which we'll try it out you know maybe it
got hung up on something so we'll let it
do its thing we still have some other
things that we we need to change in here
so I'd like to show you what we've done
with these sections actually let's let's
change this
so if you notice let me switch this
around so it's easier to get to
alright so notice we have this
background image and it's just kind of
scrolling like almost like a parallax
style for this big hero section and then
you know we just have some text here
kind of station well it's a it's
actually stationary but it looks like
it's it's moving up over top of the
image right so that's kind of like that
parallax effect so we're just gonna
change these and you can see how we've
done this we have this whole section
with the ID of home is a wrapper for
everything we set a background on this
this section and that's where that that
image is and if you really want to see
the CSS of how we did that let me know
in the live chat and I'll make sure I
show you that CSS before before I end
the stream basically that is a
background image
and then within that we just have some
divs that are there for alignment and
then we have an h1 and an h4 right we've
just centered them done a bit of styling
and then we just we have a button right
that's just an a tag that's styled in a
particular way alright so not too
difficult so we do need to change some
of this text the only thing it looks
like the changes won't mess anything up
if the text were to be too large that
could be a problem
but I think we'll end up with less text
overall which I always think is good for
that hero section professionally
grounded faith faith inspired so that'll
be our change for that and then for here
we're gonna say Master of Arts and
clinical mental health counseling okay
and I'll save that let's check on this
Wow it's still doing its thing okay not
really a problem we're about to take a
break and go to the live chat anyway so
it'll have you know a little while to to
work I do want to scroll down so I mean
you all if you want to take a closer
look at any of this let me know and of
course you're welcome to check it out in
the github repo as well this section is
where we're gonna look at now it's the
white Franciscan section ok so there's
actually let's see - let's scroll down
here so there's actually two sections
here one is hidden right now and those
are these large cards but the second one
is only really visible actually me let
me inspect this I think this will be
easier overall to change the screen size
so I've right clicked and clicked on
inspect and that's opened up chrome dev
tools if you're not familiar with dev
tools it is a really really awesome tool
for web developers and you know you
could see the whole Dom tree all the
HTML elements right and you can see all
the CSS that's attached to them but I
really want to use it right now just to
be able to make this window smaller
there we are so you can see at a certain
screen width it changes because I don't
want users have to scroll for a really
long time on mobile so we've changed it
and made these smaller cards and you
could see they just have this little
effect where they open and close it's
just a little pop-out okay so that's
what we need to change right now and we
have about a minute
so let's uh let me just show you so this
is the section where it's at
so what we're using we have the mark-up
repeated in to two different sections so
the first one let's see if I can this
will make it easier to see so basically
you have two different sections and the
one says hide on large only alright so
that's those large cards that are fully
expanded and then the second one and
this is for oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
the first div is actually the mobile
section but we're hiding it on large
screens so reverse what I just said the
second section is the one that only
shows on large screen so this is the
large cards and this is the the smaller
kind of accordion style so we'll need to
make changes in both of them and that's
what we'll do in the
next Pomodoro session but right now my
timer is about to go off oh it just went
off great I'm gonna take a short break
and hopefully this will work while I'm
taking this break I'm gonna scroll up to
where I left off in the live chat and
answers many questions as I can in this
five minute period him himangshu asked
what type of HTML update it was about so
I mean I've already answered that
hopefully uh let's see question says can
you speak Hindi no unfortunately I don't
speak Hindi so if if your English is not
very good and you'd like to ask me a
question in Hindi go ahead and type it
in to the live chat and I'll use Google
Translate to try to translate that and
hopefully I'll have to answer in English
but that may be a little bit easier for
you we do have some other people in the
chat that can speak Hindi so they may be
able to help translate as well
John Hanson says I'll be curious if
Visual Studio code will do any lint
checks for the HTML yeah I'm a little
interested to see if any Auto formatting
and things happen with Visual Studio
code since I've built this in Adam we'll
see I mean it shouldn't really have an
impact on the site but it may switch up
the way everything looks in the code a I
use deep ask what is yarn so yarn is a
JavaScript package manager so if you're
familiar with node package manager yarn
does the same thing when it first came
out it was faster and it included a lock
file which NPM didn't have but now NPM
the the latest version also has a lock
file and it's also pretty fast so at
this point me using yarn is just out of
habit
and I know the commands that I like them
but NPM does the same thing so you can
go with either one it just installs lots
of JavaScript code for you automatically
I say that you can use it in your
projects
see
all right greg has a question about that
Pomodoro timer and how long do I set it
for when I use Pomodoro timer I take 25
minute coding sessions and then
five-minute breaks and after I do 4 of
those sessions I take a 10 minute break
I have seen other people do different
amounts of times but this is how I
learned how to do it with with these
times and so I've stuck with it during
that short break usually it's not like a
complete break that's when I like I'll
check my emails or if I've have just
have other things I need to work on I'll
go back to that occasionally if I don't
have any emails so I'll just just relax
for a few minutes try to clear my
thoughts and before I get back into the
code but the idea is during that break
you don't want to really think about the
code directly right you want to give
your mind a break just kind of to sort
through things all right Greg says I'd
like to see the CSS ok good so after
this next session I will go through some
of the CSS of how I'm doing some of
these things
[Music]
ok Phoenix did does say it's mostly just
background attachment fixed property and
CSS yeah that is how we do it so I will
go through and show the CSS on the
screen but that is basically you know
how we do it with the background
attachment fix I have heard that that
can be a little bit resource intense
intensive so just be careful with it I
would never use background attachment
fixed on lots of images on the same page
I almost exclusively just use it in one
place per page and otherwise you may
have some some janky nough Swit the
scroll okay didn't quite get through
every all the questions so let me mark
down somewhere where I left off at
let's just do it here I'm gonna open up
a new terminal and let's see where we
get 29 okay so my time
12:20 9 p.m. is the timestamp on the
question where i'm gonna pick up at next
time Wow no it's that's wild
I'm not sure why that's taking so long
oh right is that we we can work around
it if we need to well let me start the
timer alright so we left off kind of
just showing where we need to make the
changes on you know the actual site and
then we also found it in the code so
let's go in here we're actually just
going to remove these sections so let's
go to this first one first and we'll
scroll down to the section that has that
are affordable ok so you can see and
we're using materialized so we've if
this whole thing is just an unordered
list so if in each Li we have two divs
the first div is the header okay so we
mark that as collapsible header with a
class and then we have the body which is
collapsible body within the body we did
put some P tags in but we could put
whatever we wanted in that in that body
but what we need to do here is just
remove this Li completely okay so we
evidently we no longer want to advertise
this program as affordable so I don't
know I don't make the marketing
decisions so I don't know whether that's
a good idea or not a good idea but I
that's that's the instructions that that
I have let's see why Franciscan oops I
accidentally minimized the entire
our section instead of just this part
there we are
so let's minimize that and now let's
open up this section and find that same
thing so we need to look for affordable
there we are so we're gonna remove in
this case you can see we have everything
split up each section is split up into
columns
so the first div gives us column classes
we split up the entire site into twelve
columns and we say based on the screen
size how many columns we wanted to take
up now in this case we've actually set
it to always be full width when we've
done these two sets of columns here
really we don't need that second piece
probably at some point I had different
values here and then I just I left it in
what I'm gonna leave it in there now
don't really want to go through
refactoring on this stream then within
that column we make we have another div
with a class of card so just to kind of
show you what's going on here so you can
see this is the card this box here on
the page and each card has some certain
styling like two pixel border radius we
have a specific box shadow for a card
and so and in a different color so you
see the background is pure white on the
cards and it's off light or slightly
gray in the normal background so that's
what our card div does and then inside
the card we have certain sections so we
have a div for the card content and in
this case everything in this particular
cards going inside that this helps
because it adds some some you know basic
padding and things we don't want our
text right up against the edge that
doesn't look nice and then finally you
know we have within there we have our
card title and we've we've made these
you know spans to give it you know a
particular look card so it'll tekzilla'
gee that's interesting I want
why I left this in here looks like I
copied and pasted this from previous
website and never got rid of that class
so it's kind of fun to look back in this
what was I doing
and then within this card content we've
also put a paragraph tag a P tag and
with our our text in here and we've
given it a class of flow text and
materialized CSS it comes with a class
called flow text which actually changes
the font size of the text based on the
screen width which i think is really
cool but in this case we need to remove
this section all the other sections are
laid out the same way all the other you
know for the different cards we're gonna
save that and it looks like we need to
make one more change and this is just a
text change let's check on first let's
check on what's going on here Wow still
nothing I'm really wishing that I would
have installed all those packages first
now so I just I didn't think it would
take that long you know I just wanted to
show you all the process so it looks
like we may not get to see all the
packages installed after all we need to
go down to where we find the affordable
card oops I'm sorry the supportive card
which should have been right under the
affordable one so supportive and we're
just gonna add in a bit of text so right
after this help we're gonna put our
students I'm sorry
students and faculty and students and
cohort style learning
okay so close interactions between
faculty and students and cohort style
learning help you feel supported
throughout your academic career okay
looks good I'm just gonna copy and paste
this as well cuz we're gonna use the
same text
up here in this other section as well
and oh yeah
whoops I did it again I closed the wrong
wrong thing we're going to close this
open this this is our mobile accordion
style sex so in here that's where I'm
gonna paste in the new stuff there we
are okay so now we have our text here
and it looks like those are all the
changes that we need so now let's make
sure that it all looks all right let's
see what our so since we never change
the styles this will work for us to be
able to see what's on the page without
having our server running so we would
have had a gulp server running but and
that would compile our s CSS or sass for
us but we made no changes so we should
be good luckily we didn't have to make
any changes so I'm just gonna open up
did it work oh it worked yes cool okay
so let's do I believe it's gold watch
it'll let me know if that's not the
right command I'm I'm not gonna go over
this unless you all want me to because
this is definitely not basic HTML stuff
here let's see what's let's open this up
here so we can see our changes
but basically what gulp watch is doing
for us is it's gonna watch all our files
and it's serving up our website locally
so that every time you make a change it
automatically is reflected here
otherwise we would have to do a manual
refresh which is not a big deal but it
takes an extra second or so if you're
working on a site day in and day out all
those seconds it starts to get pretty
annoying to have to do that so much
better when you do this it also lets you
do cool things like you do your CSS in
sass syntax SCSS syntax and it
automatically compiles it for you which
is very cool so let's just check out you
know did our right we don't have
affordable in here anymore it's gone we
have our cohort style learning text in
there we have our new our new text here
it looks good and we have our new logo
but we can see there's some issues with
our new logo we don't have the proper
padding so let's compare write this logo
worked probably because the this is a
ping file and it Canton built in with
some padding so we didn't have to add it
ourselves did we yeah
so what we need to do here since our SVG
didn't really come in with a knot it
doesn't have enough padding built in we
need to add it so let's check out in dev
tools so we're gonna inspect it whenever
we need to make CSS changes I really
like to make the changes in dev tools
first just so that I can see it you know
immediately and then I transfer it once
I'm happy with how it looks then I
transfer the code over to our actual
files you can even set up dev tools so
that it will actually edit your files
from dev tools it'll edit them I haven't
had it set up yet
maybe one day I'll do it like that
because that does seem like a cool
feature that would be you know it would
save some time all right so here's our
logo here's our image and then it's
wrapped in an a tag that's interesting
let's see okay so our image actually is
over
hanging a bit and it's not really the
end of the world that it's doing this I
don't like it let's see
yeah that's odd wonder why our image did
we set a height let's see if there's a
height set on there actually you know
what I'm I'm sorry this is this font way
too small let me make it bigger okay
that's a bit bigger and I know my my
face is probably covering up a bit of
this so I'll try to make sure that I
scroll properly so that you all can see
it may still be a bit too small I'm
afraid to make it much bigger though
because we won't be able to see enough
for it to pretty even make sense
whoops yeah you know what I'm not
exactly sure why we're getting such a
weird height on this interesting okay
well we can at least switch it up and
say I I really do want the margin let's
change up our margins here so I I don't
want margin top at all I want to set a
margin all the way around so let's do
just regular margin and we're gonna set
our top value to 8 pixels and we're this
is just gonna be to start we're gonna
set our oops
our next value which will be our right
margin to zero you don't really need a
March in there our bottom margin let's
set to 8 pixels and then our left margin
we're gonna set to 8 pixels
hey now already we can see an issue here
and that this header does not resize
compared to this so
probably gonna have to manually change
the heights of this nav yeah and
actually I don't really like that idea I
I don't think this nav needs to be
bigger than that I like it to be a
little bit more slim so we can decrease
the size of this logo and then that way
we can keep the header the same size so
we're gonna give this logo a height of
60 pixels now it makes it a lot smaller
but we can go with a smaller logo here
because we have this big FUS at the top
and actually Franciscan II research
doing though yep so you can see here the
words are just not that easy to read so
we couldn't go any smaller now you know
what I just thought of this I wonder if
I'm gonna go with this logo right now
but I wonder if the the logo that
actually says the word Franciscan would
be better here at least on the desktop
we certainly have the space for it so
maybe maybe that might be the way to go
yeah let me see what you all think let
me know what you all think about that
should we go with the one that says
Franciscan at least on desktop yeah well
um yeah we'll have to see about that for
now I think this works and let's change
this now in our actual SAS file so we
have our Styles dot s CSS file if you're
familiar with normal CSS and you've
never seen this it might look a bit
weird at first first of all you notice
we have variables for all our colors
okay so when I go to say a color down
below I don't need to put the hex value
I just
the variable this is really nice because
later on if I wanted to change the theme
I could just change all these colors up
here and then it would automatically
change them throughout all the rest of
the CSS really really kind of cool let's
see we need to go to logo right no
social side nav logo so we haven't
styled that yet let's check our nav
brand logo image yep this is it this is
what we need so if you remember we we
lower the size to 60 and then we changed
instead of margin top we're gonna do
regular margin and we did eight pixels
and zero eight pixels and most of us
eight pixels right yeah I was eight all
the way around not that this really
mattered you know entirely but that's
what we have here so when we save it
you'll see it will change in the CSS
folder so right now this is white
meaning it hasn't changed but it should
change colors once we change this I'm
gonna save it there we are so you can
see we had a color change all right to
indicate that these files were modified
right so we could see our CSS so they
automatically changes the sass syntax
into CSS which is important because
browsers can interpret CSS but not sass
so not this s CSS so it's nice to be
able to develop with this because we
have features like those variables that
I showed you
but unfortunately browsers can't handle
that with the latest versions of CSS
though you can do things like variables
so there's
need for scss but you know it's still if
you're already used to using it it's
still valuable if you haven't used it
yet I would probably just learn the
newer versions of CSS and not worry
about learning s CSS now that's just my
opinion I may be missing some you know
reasons why you would want to learn it
but from my experience I'd say you know
just don't don't worry about it unless
you have to you know if you're working
on an old project that uses it obviously
you need to learn it but otherwise you
really shouldn't need it so we can see
we'll do a refresh just to make sure
that anything we put in there is taken
out of the dev tools to ensure our
styles are still there so there's our
Styles it works it looks okay let's go
down a bit so we can make this sidebar
happen there we are and now we can check
so here our logo still works which is
great and then here actually our logo it
still works here it's interesting let's
inspect this okay all right so a few
things that I don't like about this this
a tag is not okay I guess it works I was
worried that you couldn't click okay so
that works
I think the image could actually be
bigger and it would be okay so actually
that's that's interesting
all right let me show you what I what I
mean by that so our side nav logo
should I have a height of 80 pixels but
it seems that we've I messed up at some
point so I should not have given this
the class brand logo I should take that
class out so let's see what happens when
we remove that class whoa okay
so Wow all right let's check out where
we're using brand logo oh you know what
I know why brand logo probably comes
it's probably one of the classes that
comes built-in so I still want to take
it out and let's add in some styles of
our own okay I didn't I wasn't a hundred
percent happy with that the way that was
styled and I do I want to keep the
styles for these two logos separate so
instead let's style it here just in dev
tools and let's see so that class was
actually on this a tag but what I'm
gonna do is put some Styles directly on
this image so let's go with heights side
nav logo okay so the Li is logo so the
Li itself has a height of 80 okay all
right that makes more sense now
okay so on the image itself let's go
with a width of 100% there we go
that makes it a bit smaller we
definitely want a margin on the top and
bottom so let's go margin eight pixels
and then zero for the sides and it's too
tall so it's the height 70 pixels see
what that gets us down to yeah that's
still too small I want this to be a bit
bigger see what I'd I'd like is this to
line up with this side and that looks
about right so let's take it to 94
pixels and then what we'll need to do
with this li is make the height 94
pixels so that they match and then we'll
make sure now you know that's it needs
to be larger than that let's take it up
to 110 there we are great and we still
need hmm we don't want this to change
color when we hover over it so we have
to make sure that we we do that as well
okay so let's make the changes before we
forget what they are so our side nav
logo
this is going to be would we go to up to
110 110 pixels and within logo we want
to do this a tag and on the a tag we
want to make this have a and hover like
that and then also so within sass you do
nesting so it saves us from typing here
and then it gets interpreted in the CSS
like you know side nav dot logo you know
and then there'd be another one side nav
dot logo :
you know hover right so there would it
would make it normal CSS but we can take
advantage of you know kind of this this
nesting that looks nice alright and then
one more we need whoops within the a tag
we have our image tag so let's do the
image and within our image let's just
copy what we've done here save us the
typing and there we are let's save that
yes I should change my indentation so
we're gonna save that and see what it
looks like here after we give it a
refresh sometimes it's it's good to
refresh the page because what you've
done in dev tools will stay there so you
won't you'll think that what you've done
works but really it's just what you did
in dev tools beforehand so you want to
clear that all out first so if you only
change one thing you could probably do
it manually whoa see after I refreshed
it we can see there's some crazy stuff
going on here and it looks like I forgot
to say
I've in index I forgot to remove that
brand logo class I did it in dev tools
but not in my actual HTML so that's what
we're gonna do right now there we are
which to be honest with you we don't
really need these logos to be links
because it's a one page site so like why
you don't need to navigate anywhere so
it we don't need links like that but
anyway alright cool so this looks
alright we hover over this we don't get
a weird color change and it's this is
not overlapping wonderful okay as I'm
looking at the site I see so many other
things that I would want to change but I
can't I can't take the time right now
this is not my main project so I'm gonna
stick with what I was given so for now
looks like this works yeah everything
looks fine everything works
oh my timer ran out so let me go to the
live chat here and here's what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do another 5 minute break
and then I'm gonna show you how we push
these changes to github and how I update
the site and that'll be the last thing
that we do for this dream ok I'm trying
to just pick up right where I left off
with the questions and the live chat
okay Gregg asks is there any way to get
the background to scroll to just to the
slower rates yeah definitely you can do
that so you witch
you would do in that case is most like
you you'd want to use some JavaScript to
change the scroll change the position on
the page of that image on scroll so
you're gonna need an event listener for
the scroll and then tied to that it's
gonna change the directly change the I
guess since the background image it
would be the background position of that
that image so it can be done I think so
the the guy Travis who used to do the
dev tips show I think he did a show on
parallax images where he shows where you
can do that so if you check out his
channel and try to maybe search in his
videos for the term parallax check out
his videos on that and he he does a lot
with that if you're interested go cool
says I'm inch I'm a civil engineering
student from India my passion was to
learn computer science so I'm going to
drop out of my college and learn
computer science by watching these
tutorials that's a big decision I just
say if that's what you really want to do
go for it but definitely think about it
I'm not sure how far you are in your
engineering program but if you're close
to being done with it you might want to
think about sticking with it or if you
have some sort of scholarship where you
can go to school without paying that
much money you may want to think about
it as well otherwise I'd say you know go
for it good luck and you know definitely
will try to help you here and in this
stream as much as we can and there are a
lot of good free resources out there to
help you learn Michael notice the
unnecessary aids egg as well you
probably noticed that way before I did
most likely what I had done is copied
this
were from somewhere else either one of
my previous projects or maybe the like
the default template for materialized
and just never changed it
yet the hashtag as the hf is it just
takes you to like you just stay on the
same page right if you don't know what
you want to link to you can just put
that in there and you'll stay on the
same page it's some more like a
placeholder so it's there but it doesn't
really do anything in this case Oh hard
should ask where's palm poem the dark
theme timer you know what since I'm on
my laptop this was already open I don't
think I ever used pom-pom on my laptop
because normally I stream from work so
I'll have to switch to that because I do
love that dark theme
okay and Lee also asked to show some of
the CSS so I will definitely do that
Lucas says good morning good morning
thanks for watching
go cool asks says are you in college no
I'm not in college I work for a college
okay I am skipping a lot of the
conversation that's in between people so
if you watch the replay you should be
able to see the chat like as it happened
during the livestream so you can check
that out if you want but I don't want
you all to think that I'm ignoring the
chat but just trying to to skip over to
make sure I get to all the questions
alright I'm gonna set this 25 minute
timer for another session I really don't
expect this to go longer than 25 minutes
though since everything's pretty much
done we just need to to make it live so
here's a few things that we need to do
we do need to make like we need to build
this so it goes in the dist and we need
to double check that the logos go over
so I don't remember on this project if I
have it set up to automatically push
images into the dist folder we'll see
but here's what we we need to do I'm
gonna get rid of or I'm gonna stop this
this server we don't really need it
right now and I'm gonna do a gulp dist
all right so this is gonna change our
files we'll see how long it takes there
we are
so it looks like nothing injected in
base let's double-check to make sure a
change really did happen in dist yep it
changed let's see what files changed in
particular so our CSS did its expected
and our index did all right great now
notice this side nav logo is still there
so evidently I don't have it set up to
pull over images so let's manually
change this you see I didn't really have
that many images so I suppose I just
figured hey why take the trouble to set
that up if I'm not I mean
it and let's copy this and see four let
me paste it yep
all right cool so now we have this logo
here as well and now let's do a git
commit so let's check our status for get
if you're not familiar with using git
it's a way to track all your changes and
have lots of little tiny like save
points for your code so that you can go
back to previous points if you mess
something up and you can see the whole
history of the project you can see what
if there are multiple people working on
it you can see who did what
you know when so there's a lot a big
advantage to using this get is one of
the most popular version control systems
there are other systems and if you use
git you can store your code and all your
your get commits on github so that other
people can view it and help out with
your code so that's what we're doing
here so what I want to do first is to
get add and I'm gonna put a period means
add everything so now if we do another
get status you can see we've changed you
know everything is now green that means
it's ready to be committed it's an it's
staged now in the staging area so before
we had some stuff was red and modified
some stuff says deleted and this stuff
was totally new and wasn't being tracked
at all now everything's here so the next
step is to do a git commit and I'm gonna
use this em flag here so - em and that's
gonna allow me to do a commit message
right there in line so a commit message
is gonna be update or it's gonna be add
new logo and text alright it's pretty
general I try to keep the commit
messages really short so we probably
could say a bit more about exactly what
we changed but we'll be able to see on
github exactly what changed so we don't
really need to describe every
right that's not what the commit message
is for so that looks good I'm gonna hit
enter here and we'll see that's all
committed now we can do a get push and
that's gonna send all that up to github
so if any of you are checking out the
github repo now if you refresh the page
you'll see all those changes are now
there in the github repo now - I have
what's called a flight plan setup to
push this stuff to the server this
doesn't always work so let's see if
it'll work and if it does work then I'll
explain how it works if it doesn't work
then I'll just update manually later but
let's try this
we'll go fly the command is fly
production and what it should do is
automatically log into our server and
move all the files over and we have to
do we have to run our gulp this and our
get stuff before we do this because it
uses get to determine what files change
and it only copies over the files that
change so instead of copying over all
your files all the time it saves a lot
of time by just copying what's changed
so it's it's pretty cool all right cool
so it looks like that worked let's
verify by going to the live site and you
all can do this too if you go to the
live site and let's refresh the page
awesome really cool great that works
let's double check down here yep looks
like everything's fine
everything works let's do a check for
the mobile size just to be sure all
right
looks good okay looks okay that does
look a bit big to me now that I see it a
probably look huge on mobile it's
acceptable for now this is a very low
traffic site so it's not it's not a
great use of my time to nitpick the
design here I mean I'd love to have all
my sites be perfect but realistically I
need to be aware of the value of my time
and the value of each project and this
one is just not it's not likely to bring
in enough value to university to justify
putting that much more time into it at
this point if I get some what other
projects finished and have a little bit
of time where I'm not really working on
anything that never happens but if it
happens then it would be a good idea to
come back to it but right now there the
main website is more important but it
looks like yep
everything looks good all right cool so
we've successfully pulled down a
repository from github we've cloned it
we've installed all the proper packages
on our machine we've changed out images
we've changed out text we've updated the
CSS to handle what we've done with the
image oK we've used an SVG image in
place of a ping and we successfully use
trace a trans filed s CSS or compiled
site I don't know we've converted s CSS
into CSS right we've behind the scenes
everything actually got minified as well
when we did our our gulp disk command
all right and then we've pushed all
those changes up to the server using
flightplan
j s and updated it on get so we did get
a lot done and now I'm gonna go back I'm
gonna stop this timer
because we don't really need it anymore
and I'm gonna go through all of the
changes or I'm sorry all of the rest of
the questions and comments in the live
chat and then we'll finish up for today
I also want to let you all know I'm
gonna try to do stream tomorrow but I
may not be able to because I'm gonna be
speaking at the moms can code virtual
summit at 1:00 p.m. Eastern Time so if
anyone's interested you can sign up I
don't think it's very expensive to sign
up it's been going on all week so
there's still talks today tomorrow and
all day Friday so if you're interested
you know check it out
probably well that probably won't be
available that video except on the moms
can code platform but so if I can stream
I it'll probably be earlier in the day
so I'll do what I can I'll try to get a
stream in but I may not be able to but
I'll definitely try to stream on Friday
and use my my new webcam which hopefully
will be in by them alright Michael
criolla asked why use two separate divs
and not media queries okay so we
actually are using media queries and div
so behind the scenes we have let me
scroll down to where those are for
instance okay so behind the scenes this
class hide on large only is is actually
media queries and hide on medium and
down or media queries to say whether or
not something is hidden or shown so so
we want to display really entirely
different things depending on the screen
width so we're using the media queries
to just you give something a
display:none
or a display:block
John Henson says are the name attributes
on divs for hash Crowell and div it
should be data name instead of name for
this attribute shows how well browsers
are very forgiving HTML yes so the the
name
yeah the name is for what I have a it is
so normally you can just use anchor tags
to scroll down the page but the scroll
is very abrupt so I don't like that so
it just made a little JavaScript
function that slows down the rate of
scroll so it looks a little bit nicer
yeah and I guess you can use data name
yeah it really I don't know if it will
matter but at this point at least
browsers are fine with this with these
custom properties so it doesn't really
matter if you use data name or not I
don't know is there some plan to make it
so that you can't do these and you have
to use data name if there is it'd be
good to know about but yeah as far as
it's been my experience that you know
these custom attributes work without
prefixing it with data -
yeah Jonah John Hanson said yes s yeah
haven't used it in a while
mark pag Paglia asks if anyone is using
notepad notepad QQ 4 blue - I I don't
use Ubuntu as a desktop operating system
so I definitely have not there are a few
people that do use it I think in that
watch the stream sometimes so they might
be able to let you know
let's see
Zach s if I was laying in bed no I'm not
I'm laying in a recliner but actually
that um it's probably misleading because
I like this literally is like a
tablecloth that serves was like my wall
for my office in the basement so it
probably does look like I'm laying in
bed because it looks like a sheet or
something how cool would it be if you
had a setup where your monitors were
like on the ceiling and you could just
lay in bed and code it probably hard to
stay awake though but it would be the
most comfortable setup yeah Zach says
cozy coder yeah when I work from home it
definitely is very comfortable
Zach also says nice code editor Thanks
and he says Annie uses yarn a little
little heart symbol laughter so yeah
definitely definitely like yarn Alex
asks did I just hear a lady in the
background speaking Portuguese you may
have heard someone in the background
because my wife is just she's actually
like right next to me on an exercise
bike doing some coding as well I think
she's actually trying to take an
Instagram pic right now so either she
doesn't speak Portuguese she may have
been listening to talk on the moms can
code virtual summit so I'm actually I
think I'm missing a talk right now which
I was hoping to be finished early enough
to not miss one but oh well yeah but I
don't know about poor she's
okay horseshit saying enable editor dot
format on save on vs code settings okay
cool I have to do that I'm not gonna try
to do it right now because everything's
so slow in my machine it's just it's
somewhat annoying we'll see at what
point I get so annoyed that I really try
to like do something about it there is a
way that I can run OBS on a separate
computer to so that my computer will run
faster I might try to set that up
ah Frankie said I had to step away for a
moment oh yeah no problem
Frankie says we understand Jesse in
regard to skipping over comments to get
to the question smiley face
alright thanks thanks for understanding
yeah I used before I really like to read
all the comments so that people watching
later the recordings would get to see
them but now that YouTube lets people
see all the comments even on the replay
I just don't think there's a need for me
to do that
so I could keep the videos you know a
bit shorter if I don't read everything
so hopefully that's all right with you
Oh harsh it says JavaScript af progress
thoughts so JavaScript AF is a side
project that Harshad and I and Nicki
have been working on and JavaScript err
whose I don't know if javascript is here
or not right now
so realistically Harshit has been doing
a ton of the work lately and Nicki I
haven't done much at all but we're
hoping to launch soon it's basically
just gonna be a like a web app where you
can go to highlight some of your github
repositories and you can vote and I'd
like to highlight some of the JavaScript
repositories that are not very
well-known see you know we all know what
the top repositories are like react is
huge right so you know it people know
about those but I want to get to like
that next level of repositories the you
know they're doing really cool things
but maybe they're not getting noticed so
this would be kind of an easier way to
just check out javascript repositories
search for them and let people know what
you think is is really cool that's going
on so that should be launching sometime
in May I think but anyway horseshit I I
think everything's going well so far
I haven't had a ton of time to check you
know check out all the details but in
terms of functionality it's getting
really close to being
complete all right so Phoenix says the
logo and the side menu look huge I
checked in my machine yeah I was afraid
of that maybe I'll go back in and change
it I'm not gonna do it right now but
I'll check it out on my cellphone and
just to see if it's like extremely too
big then I'll go back in and change it
see Ana says thanks for you oh you're
welcome no problem thanks for watching
and in a watches frequently so it always
has really good questions
not always code related but that's kind
of cool why they get to talk about other
stuff so thanks to that in a Dmitri says
Jessie you're very good man I see your
streams always oh thanks thanks I
appreciate it thanks for watching Harry
asked if Rico camp was down I have no
idea I haven't tried to log into free
code camp today so it's possible I
didn't see so I don't have anything to
do with like the servers for the free
kill camp out at work so I I can't do
anything about that sorry if they are
down though I'm sure they'll be working
on them to get them up as soon as
possible
Phoenix says it looks even bigger in
mobile yeah maybe I will have to change
that then michael says by the way I got
a scholarship for Google's mobile
specialist nano degree on Udacity it's a
six month program that cost $1,200 so
I'm kind of stoked hopefully I'll find a
remote job by the time it's finished Wow
congratulations congratulations that is
awesome I'm really really happy for you
you definitely have to let me know how
it's going other programs going on and
what kind of cool stuff you're learning
that's that's really cool
no life says hi I'm new to coding now I
am learning HTML CSS at w3 schools when
is a good time to start making something
on my own is HTML CSS good enough to
make something for my portfolio or
should I learn JavaScript first you can
definitely do really cool stuff with
with CSS in HTML you know check out on
code pen a lot of the cool stuff that
people do without JavaScript so you can
definitely make things with just CSS and
HTML that are awesome to put on your
portfolio
Sarah Dresner does so much really cool
stuff with CSS trying to cou else drawn
a blank
alright my wife's name from there
Kristina Gorton from coffee craft code
does really cool stuff with CSS
oona Kravitz does really cool stuff so
check them out find them on Twitter and
and check out what they're doing but
yeah definitely obviously if you want to
do this as a career you would you want
to learn some JavaScript but if you just
really feel like making something cool
then HTML and CSS are definitely enough
to get started with it
alright Michael says thanks went through
the three-month try out and got the news
about getting to the finals yesterday
that's really awesome
actually my wife went through the tryout
as well and and she just found out she
got into the the frontend nanodegree so
I'd have I know I know what you were
going through Michael with that at least
from you know from watching my wife go
through it so yeah really really happy
for you again congratulations Alex said
it sounded like she was scolding a kid
in Portuguese
she was probably scolding a kid but not
in Portuguese though that would sound
cool okay so it looks like free code
camp may actually be down right now so
her should ask if he can put the link in
here for JavaScript af yeah for sure put
the link in if it locks you
oh I'll allow it I'll show it we just
lost my place it scrolled me down
automatically arches are soo that some
of the people can give testing data I
need data yeah yeah for sure that's a
great idea so let's put the link in here
you know what Harshit I can is it the
same link you gave me earlier for
testing let me see if I can find it
maybe I closed it I hope I didn't close
it I'm I think I may have closed it I'll
have to looks like Cara's gonna put the
link in so
well okay so freako camp is working for
Harshit and it's working for Phoenix so
maybe it's back online Reggie says are
you using any CSS framework yes so for
this particular project I'm using
materialized CSS it is a bit of an older
version of materialized so it may look
different than you know if you're used
to using the updated version let's see
michael says tell the wife
congratulations well a bank michael says
congratulations she says thanks alright
hard [ __ ] I didn't nothing came up in
the live chat I don't know if you're
trying to put put the link in there or
not the beep sound that was the we have
an exercise bike and I guess something
happened did you do all right so she was
she's won an hour on the exercise bike
and that was the timer
how I said it kind of triggered me the
beep noise triggered you okay to here
would it be alright so there's the link
I wasn't clickable let me let me do a
clickable version alright so there's a
link now it's JSA f now SH if you'd like
to check out the the project the side
project that I described a little bit
earlier you'll go there sign in with
your github account and then click on
the little edit icon in the bottom right
hand corner and add some of your
repositories to JavaScript AF and
that'll give us some more data please
give some feedback on what you think and
hopefully this would be a good thing for
the whole you know community yet you
know that's the goal so if you want to
you know help out working on it or
submit a pull request or anything it's
it's on github
I believe you can find the repository
for it on JavaScript they have so when
you get in there you can
see it and you can check it out
contribute you know how whatever you
want
oh yeah harsh it says feel free to make
issues on get up yeah if you see
something that's messed up go to the
github repo and make an issue that'll be
the near the best way and put any detail
screenshots whatever you need to to
explain the issue Rajesh's do you have
any JavaScript es6 tutorials I haven't
done one personally but on this channel
the free code camp YouTube channel we I
believe we do have some some tutorials
so just search for that among the videos
I think we have some I may do some
tutorials along those lines on my own
YouTube channel so if you're interested
in in my own videos tutorial videos
check out the link in the description
and subscribe to my channel I've been a
little behind on making videos but now
that I'm I'm buying what I need to have
a more proper setup for doing videos
hopefully I'll be able to get you'll get
more done one of the issues with making
videos before was low quality and then
if I tried to use my camera on my phone
which is a good quality I didn't have a
tripod so it was kind of always at an
awkward angle so anyway I'm hoping to
make some new videos soon it's been a
while since I've done that and let's see
phoenix asks
Jesse what is Gator it's just like a
chat thing so you can go on there and
you know we chat about the stream and
help each other out with things alright
so I'm at the bottom of the chat now and
this has been an hour and a half long
stream so definitely a nice nice length
here thank you all so much for watching
and for helping out I know we I think we
had a lot of new viewers cuz at one
point we had a hundred and three viewers
on at the same time which is which is
really really awesome so if you're new
and you you liked it come on back we do
a lot of things although
from basic.html up to more advanced
react things we do some back-end stuff
occasionally set up servers like we we
do a lot most most of what you would
need to be a front-end developer or a
little bit of like back-end as well we
do here so and let me know I love
feedback on the stream so send me a
message you know somewhere I'm on
Twitter I'm on all the social media
stuff so you know send me a message let
me know what I can improve about these
dreams I want to make it better for you
all let me know what you like about them
and I may be back tomorrow tomorrow I
got a lot going on so may not be able to
stream tomorrow but I think Friday I'm
pretty sure I'll be able to do a stream
so I'll see you all then and until then
have a wonderful day